herzlich willkommen zum juni vom
internetportal faszination punkte erster
stelle zumal es ganz großes dankeschön
fürs viel lob und die viele komplimente
und nicht wie hoch es freut mich sehr
sehr fest und umso mehr freut es mich
dass ich ganz viel feedback bekommt wo
luft
wasserburg sind außerdem faszination
verspürt wie zb fabian termin wann zeit
sich in sand für die tolle und
geheimnisvolle reportage mir geht es
genau gleich ich liebe es in den bergen
nach dem bunker zu schauen wieder einen
neuen zu entdecken er schiebt das sind
zum wanderer und autofans zum sonnen
mystischer punkten wir hören ein deckel
aus schimborn nicht nur michaels hoch
mit dem mit dem geheimnisvollen gefühl
wieder hier auffällig geschichte sauber
las vegas oder sogar die militaria
punkte wie zum beispiel plötzlich kurz
firesheep super reportage habe mich in
meine zeit die zeit zurück versetzt
gefühlt in einigen dieser bunker war ich
auch meine kollegen starten immer wieder
wenn ich aus dieser zeit erzählen
es sind objekte zeit zeugen welche man
den jüngeren generation zeigen muss kann
mobil kein internet da muss man
verzichten und ganz einfach lieben es
war toll das findet lukas seit er ist
weg ein bunker verbracht war jeweils
sehr gemütlich dort drin also weiß nicht
wir merkten dass es wirklich tatsächlich
isst dann hat tagelang kreis sind und
das sei zwischen paraguay wo selber
bielefeld wurden ist er es also in der
es in mails absolviert war eine
spezielle zeit viele punkte gesehen
darin tage verbraucht werde es selber
nicht erlebt hat weiß nicht wie es ist
tagelang ohne sonnenlicht eingesperrt zu
sein also endet nicht als so schön
jährige wieder lockt unter patrick und
ich stelle das aber auch schwierig weil
nur schon ich bin ehrlich ich vier
stunden insgesamt eine andere abstand
bin ich wieder im bunker xi und womit am
schluss kurz kurz vor schluss im bett
beim notausgang user und noch nicht
einmal
mit den augen so umstellen und sah dass
jetzt wieder zehn busse und da gelang
einfach gesperrt ist wirklich ohne
tageslicht ich glaube das macht festhält
bis mit ein also schon sehr speziell und
den europa kommentiert hans dass es
insgesamt ideen steht ist so
bunkeranlage verbrachte und ich hab sehr
gewundert not wie ist das eigentlich sie
zum der speziell weil sich alles kann
sie also den bau von einer sache von
einem bunker ist kein sie unter das
mandat stationiert ist keines das
mitnehmen und davor den crash dass sie
und er hätten folgendes gemeint dass
erich schütz zurück sie unternehmen als
munitions magazin dorfmuseum anfang
einfach weil man etwas zugelegt
überhaupt wisse wie vor granate zum
beispiel der klage sind und sind
katholisch aktiv die axxe und hätten
sauerstoffflaschen
nachdem r christen das sind so nimmt wie
statisch und also voll voll absurd und
wieder seite dann nur einrücken in den
wk von immer an einem bahnhof oder
sammelplatz statt und zwar unter
sogenannten kriegsbedingungen von da an
war alles tabu nur wir selber wussten
wohin es weitergeht könnte so viel ihnen
heute berichten also das ist sachlich
sondern nur sondern erfahren ich war
nicht super super spannend findet wie
bereits einige fragen zum bau von einer
anlage zum beispiel besteht überhaupt am
bau beteiligt sind das zivile leben
zählt das militär oder eventuell augen
milizsoldaten und zwei mal hinterfragt
wer hat all diese anlagen gebaut und das
ist in frage wonach der armasuisse
gestellt hat muss ich dafür zu ersteigen
wird stilllegung und für euch vor alten
bunker seehofer beantwortung verzichtet
auf dem unteren kommentar vor dem
sammeltag antwortet dass das alles
privat die filme sind nicht sehr viel
der user findet armasuisse stelle ist wo
mir das handy beantworten
die paradeiser fragt was ist ein
militärisches er schiebt nichts für viel
geld gebaut für einen feind der niemals
kam gefragt ja nicht ausgestellt sind
sie auch beantworten verzichtet aber
wohl nicht viel mehr ist nicht die frage
stellt
effektiv die tat vom red wie oder vor
der originalstrecke
groß bewaffnet und flößt hof verlegten
sie dann den über 20
kwh im marketing fragt wieso nicht die
infrastruktur für kraftwerk wie solar
wind nutzen ich weiß ganz herzlich solar
oder windenergie
effektiv kann nutzer aber
wasserkraft das wird braucht das weiß
ich meinte grímsson gebiert haben sich
so vorstellen wie ein osterhase oder
weniger kraft war oberhasli 225
gefangenen wasserkraftwerk bauen um zwei
40 beziehungsweise in seine 40 hat ein
schweizer armee dieter weil er fest ich
auf einer party sprache kam mit
kraftwerke oberhasli weil die einst nur
für wasserstoff verbraucher die sind
dann aber einig wurde nun zu achten ist
noch lang nach allen schwierig und so
mit armee dann all die festigung und
kraftwerke oberhasli hat nach dir
festigt grimsel vor der armee übernommen
und hätte kauft und die infos die
rosenburg von jost auf der mauer die
schweiz unter tag und auf einer website
facebook.com kelis archiv ist vor allem
festige vor allem banken archiviert sind
und ihre geschichte zu searchsoftware
tom robin sehr spannende doku danke
schön auch dass gewisse gemeinden eine
um zonen bewilligen strand werden zu
wissen ob uns ein paar der bunker neben
der spannenden geschichte an was auch
probleme bereiten können analog dem
munitionsdepot in mitholz audi floccari
der armasuisse stärker wo sie auch
verantworten verzichteten was mir aber
der alex lustig sagte der bild
das er vor dass seine hoheit die anlage
müsse 35 irgendwelche munitions
rückstand sollte die nächste sind
irgendwelche schadstoffe war das objekt
nicht zum alange und am swiss ski star
auf ihrer website dass sie so wie
zärtlich und lässige us wirtschaft
umwelt versuche zu verhindern beim
rückbau oder stilllegung von einer
anlage trentiner nur fleiß noch eine
frage die bist du auf die idee gekommen
eine reportage über bunker zu machen es
ist ja nicht gerade alltäglich leider
stimmt in der reportage zeit aber ich
hab selber einfach wirklich mega große
faszination mit alten bunker weil ich
sehr viel rango wanderer auf touren bin
und ich verstehe das mal wenn ich
irgendwo den berg unterwegs ist man
irgendwie sondern punkten ausgang
irgendwie
irgendwo einfach auf den bunker oder
feste kiwis und haben natürlich jedes
mal gefragt hey was ist erinnern wird es
noch etwas was ist das und die neugierde
immer größer und ich dachte ich werde
jetzt wirkt da mal demnach gar und
reportage machen ich lerne sagt fragt
schaffst du wieder in dem sfv das ist
einmalig sander 2 morgen sexy top doku
danke formal gegen herrn finden sagt und
wie du weißt zwei monaten immer aber für
rack mache ich jetzt ab und zu neue
reportage und jetzt zum schluss viele
oder einige freunde nun zweiter tag
wünscht würde natürlich mega gärten
machen aber es ist frage ich was würdet
ihr gerne allfällige zweite teil sehe
also ist vielleicht eher die mit
geschichtlicher hintergrund oder einfach
wieder auf solide bunkeranlagen
unbedingt kommentare weil das wir noch
nie hilfe für den allfälligen zweiten
teil danke viermal und bis zur nächsten
reporter